Welcome to pre frosh.
Uh,
I'm talking about black holes at seven o'clock this evening.
Come listened to that too.
Uh,
and in the meantime we'll talk about the future of the universe.
Okay.
Um,
logistical questions,
anything?
All right,
where were we?
We were here.
Uh,
this is the data that demonstrate that the universe is filled with dark energy,
are kind of anti gravity that is pushing the universe apart.
And what this is,
this is the same data,
both of these plot,
uh,
just plotted slightly differently on the top plot.
What they've done is they've plotted the apparent magnitude of these supernovae
versus their red shift and so apparent magnitude because the,
the absolute magnitude is always the same.
These are standard candles.
So from the apparent magnitude,
you can figure out what the distance modulates is.
That gives you a measure of the distance.
So this is just distance versus velocity.
Now we've plotted distance versus velocity a bunch of times.
That's the Hubble diagram.
Uh,
most of the times we've plotted it.
It's come out on a straight line.
Uh,
do you understand why this plot isn't on a straight line?
The top one I'm talking about now,
why those lines are curved.
What's the,
what's The y axis?
The y axis is,
yes,
it's logarithmic.
Thank you very much.
Uh,
yes,
it's magnitude.
Magnitude are upside down in Logarithmic,
right?
Uh,
that's why,
uh,
faint stars have high numbers,
up at the top and uh,
uh,
and because one axis is logarithmic and the other axis is,
and of course at curves,
you could,
the way you,
if you want a nice straight line,
you'd just make this access logarithmic as well.
What we've done down on the bottom is just subtracted off,
uh,
the empty universe,
a universe with no dark matte with no matter and no energy in it.
Uh,
so that you can see more clearly the way these three lines diverged.
And these three lines are three different models of the universe.
This is a,
and there,
uh,
do you noted by these Omega factors,
Alma Mater,
that that's the density of matter divided by the critical density Omega Lambda.
That's the energy density of the dark,
uh,
of the dark energy divided by that same critical density.
Uh,
and down here is,
uh,
an Omega matter of one that's the dividing line between a universe that we
collapses and a university expanse forever.
So if the universe were,
if the points that we studied were down here,
the universe would read collapsed.
If they're up here at Winn,
this dotted line here is a quarter and zero a quarter,
uh,
in,
Omeka matter is the amount of,
uh,
is the amount of matter that we actually observe in dark matter in galaxies.
If you go out and count up all the dark matter in the galaxies,
add it all up,
you get to about quarter of the critical density.
Uh,
so what people were kind of expecting to see was something between here and
here.
And of course that wasn't what happened as we discussed last time.
Turns out all the points are too high and therefore you end up the current best
fit,
the best.
Yes,
for way the way the universe is this solid line here.
Uh,
this is called the standard model or the concordance model,
uh,
where you've got a quarter of,
the Omega matter is a quarter,
but there's a whole bunch of dark energy,
uh,
three quarters of the universes in this mysterious form of dark energy,
which tends to push things apart rather than,
than pull them together.
That's why these points are above the zero line instead of below it.
And that's the current best idea for what the universe is.
So by virtue of the fact that these points lie on the solid line,
rather than on somewhere between these two dotted lines,
or perhaps even below,
uh,
we make this remarkable conclusion that the universe is three quarters full of
something we absolutely don't understand called dark energy,
which has the effect of an anti gravity.
And that it turns out that Einstein's biggest mistake is right after all,
pretty hefty conclusion to lay on the basis of two dozen point with let it be
said,
a pretty sizable error bars on any one of those points.
And so I thought,
uh,
at the start of today,
I would talk about what these points are,
how they are measured,
and what could go wrong with this kind of measurement.
Because you know,
we're Bay,
we've transformed what we think about the universe based on this.
And so it behooves one to actually try and understand what's going on.
I'll come back to that in a minute.
So what are these points?
What are we measuring?
Uh,
and why did we,
why,
why do we think it might even work?
Um,
what we are measuring is type one a supernova.
So this is typical astronomical nomenclature,
right?
Uh,
we go out,
we find a bunch of things.
We divide them into categories.
We call them type one,
type two.
It then turns out that the,
uh,
that each of those categories has subcategories.
Type one a,
uh,
the joke is,
when astronomers find three objects,
that's two categories and an exception.
Uh,
and so a type one,
a supernova though are by now a fairly well defined a category.
And here's what we think they are.
Think back to the middle part of the class.
To the black hole section of the class where we were talking about x Ray
Binary's,
x ray binary,
you'll recall is a black hole.
You in orbit around something,
some other kind of star in it pulls material from that other star onto itself.
So this is the type one come from a very similar category of object.
Here's a normal star,
except it's pulled out of shape a little bit and it's in a double star system.
Here's something else.
This is a white dwarf.
In this case you'll remember,
white dwarfs are these very compact stars.
Not Compact enough to be black holes,
but fairly compact,
uh,
that are created a at the end of the lifetime of stars like the Sun.
So fairly dense object and just as in the x,
right?
Binary stuff is being pulled off of the normal star onto the white dwarf.
So then what happens to this stuff?
First of all,
what the White Dwarf,
uh,
has had all its hydrogen and helium fuse together.
So there's no hydrogen or helium left.
So this white dwarf is composed of elements like carbon and oxygen and nitrogen
and neon and,
and salon up the line,
but no hydrogen and helium.
So the material that comes from the normal stars full of hydrogen and helium,
it's pretty much all hydrogen and helium.
So the created material,
what does it do?
A land on the white dwarf.
And uh,
as it went,
it heats up,
it falls down and he up gets very hot,
gets very dense.
And so,
uh,
it undergoes nuclear fusion just like the material in the middle of the sun or
in the middle,
presumably of this normal star as well.
So there's all this fusion going on.
One of the features of the way this works on a white dwarf is it is usually
true,
uh,
that the,
that what happens is hydrogen and helium piles up for awhile and then it has a
big explosion.
It doesn't usually burn steadily.
And so,
uh,
what,
what this actually,
what actually happens is you have occasional,
uh,
thermo nuclear explosions
of the accreted material.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
you pile up all this hydrogen and you wait some amount of time,
somewhere between 10 days and 10 to the five years,
depending on the object.
You pile up all this hydrogen and helium,
and finally it gets dance on hot enough to explode and then it explodes all at
once.
Huge hydrogen bomb on the surface of this white dwarf.
Uh,
and that makes the system much,
much brighter because there's all this stuff exploding.
These are,
this is the,
a phenomenon we call a Nova because it looked to the ancients as if a new star
had appeared because the thing had gotten so much brighter.
Okay.
So,
uh,
stuff piles up,
no fee occur,
more stuff piles up,
more Novia occur.
Uh,
and one of the things that's happening while this is going on while this is
going on is that the white dwarf is gradually getting more massive
cause it's piling up all this extra material.
Oh.
The consequence of the Nova is that all the hydrogen and helium gets fused into
carbon,
oxygen,
nitrogen,
neon,
and so forth.
So then it looks just like the rest of the white dwarf get to assimilate it into
the whiteboard,
except the white dwarf is bigger now.
So the white dwarf gets more massive,
uh,
and uh,
gradually more and more and more massive.
But you may recall there's a limit to how long this could go on.
Uh,
the reason there's a limit to how local,
how long this can go on is because of something we've talked about before.
The Chandra Sekhar limit,
which says that white dwarfs cannot be more massive than 1.4 times the mass of
the sun.
So what happens when this white dwarf,
which starts out at some perfectly respectable mass 0.6 of the sun or one,
one solar mass and it's piling up all this material from it,
uh,
from its friend,
and it gradually getting more and more massive.
And then it reaches this limit,
this Chandra state card limits.
So then what happens?
What happens?
Remember what the chanter sake.
Our limit is if you're,
if you've got a white dwarf that's bigger than the Chandra,
say card limit,
then uh,
the white dwarf cannot hold itself up against gravity.
And so the whole thing collapses all at once.
And as is generally the case,
when it collapses,
it gets hot,
it gets dance.
That's what generally happens in a collapse.
Uh,
and so the carbon in particular,
but all the other elements as well,
uh,
so carbon and other elements in the white dwarf
fuse and that generates energy.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
they fuse together to form heavy elements such as iron and heavier than that,
that
all at once.
So what happens is every time this occurs,
you have exactly the same amount of stuff.
This always happens when you have 1.4 solar mass white dwarfs,
because that's the limit.
You've gradually built up to that limit.
And so you have what you might refer to as a standard bomb.
We've talked about standard candles.
This is a standard bomb.
Uh,
all,
uh,
you always have
have
the same amount of material
and it all explodes at once.
Well,
actually it takes about 100 milliseconds,
something like that,
but basically all at once.
Um,
so you blow up 1.4 solar masses of carbon all at once.
Now the advantage of standard things is if you have a standard bomb with the
same amount of fuel,
every one of them should be exactly as bright as every other one.
And that's what we need to make these distance measurements remember?
So if you look at these things,
you see that they're always
the same
brightness.
So they're terrific standard candles.
And so one of the things that happens is,
uh,
that you look at these things and you can tell from how bright they look exactly
how far away they are.
You also measure their red shift when they,
when they blow up in this way.
Uh,
and uh,
you get to put a point on that red shift versus distance plot now and there are
stupendously bright.
These things are having an absolute magnitude of minus 19 and a half.
They out shine whole galaxies for about a week or two until they go away.
And so you can see them at enormous distances.
So they're just about the perfect thing for exploring cosmology.
Uh,
but we were only really able to do this in the,
in the starting,
in the early 1990s because there were two key advances that were made at that
time.
One is,
uh,
that the Hubble Space Telescope,
measured,
uh,
things like Cepheids and other kinds of stars,
other kinds of distance measurement,
uh,
in galaxies,
that had historically had type one a supernova.
These things don't occur very often,
uh,
once every couple of hundred years per galaxy.
Uh,
there hasn't been one in our own galaxy since before they invented the
telescope.
Uh,
we're kind of overdue actually.
one of the worrying things,
you know,
it would be great to have one of these supernova in our own galaxy.
We could study it enormously,
carefully.
The problem is all the telescopes are too big.
Uh,
and,
uh,
because it would burn out all the instruments you put one of these big research
telescopes pointing to it.
So one of the things,
uh,
that we have a Justin Case sorta for emergencies,
in the telescopes I work with in Chile is we have a big thing you can put over
the front of the telescope and stop it down to about a couple of inches across a
just in case there's a type one,
a soup or any kind of Supernova in our own galaxy.
But when these things that we do have supernova in the historical record,
uh,
Kepler and Tyco saw one a and then back in the 11th century,
there was a famous one observed by the Chinese scenario astronomers.
Uh,
the Europeans were of course in barbarity at the time.
It didn't even notice,
uh,
and uh,
which now we see the crab Nebula,
which is a big outward going explosion.
Uh,
and these things become the brightest object in the sky.
You can see him in the daytime,
uh,
pretty amazing.
Uh,
but it hasn't happened for 400 years,
at least in our own galaxy.
They last,
well,
I'll show you in a minute what the light curve looks like.
They take a couple weeks to rise to their maximum brightness and then they decay
over over a few months.
Uh,
so you can see him for a little while.
so HSD measured,
measured Cepheids.
This meant that we could calibrate them,
remember the distance ladder,
so you could calibrate these things,
right.
Calibration and this in particular meant,
uh,
that we know the absolute magnitude,
which is crucial for determining these distances.
What then came out of that and other things,
uh,
mostly actually done with ground based telescopes.
So ground based telescopes.
Yeah.
Uh,
compared,
uh,
discovered and compared many of these things,
many of these,
uh,
type one A's and discovered that,
you know,
it isn't actually quite true that they all look to be the same brightness,
uh,
because it would be true if you could measure all of the energy that came out of
these things,
but that isn't actually what you measure.
What you measure is all of the photons in a certain range depending on your
detector and how you set your telescope up,
all of your,
all photons within a certain range of wavelengths at a certain time.
Uh,
and that is not the same thing as measuring all the energy that the thing gives
out.
Uh,
and so it turns out that,
uh,
if you measure
all photons in some wavelength region at some time,
that actually varies from one object to another.
Uh,
this can vary by oh,
I don't know,
15 to 20%.
Uh,
but that's enough to cause you some real trouble in making these measurements.
But what they discovered was that you can correct for this.
Uh,
if you measure
the color and the decay rate,
that is to say how fast it gets fainter.
So your question turns out to be very important.
Uh,
these things behave differently depending on how fast they go away.
if you measure the color and the decay rate,
you can correct for some of these deviations and turn it back into a good
standard
sandal.
And I'll show you how this is done in just a second.
Okay.
How are we doing?
Okay,
let me turn this off for a second
and go back to here.
All right.
This is the key thing that was found out in the early 1990s.
What up on the top,
you have a whole observations from a whole bunch of supernovae.
This is time.
So this is zero,
20 days,
40 days,
60 days.
So this is time counting from the peak brightness.
And most of the time you can observe these things before they get to peak
brightness.
You watched them get brighter and then you watch them get fainter.
In the top plot there were plotting,
uh,
more or less absolute magnitude.
Think of it,
it's a complicated thing,
but think of it as absolute magnitude.
So minus 19 and a half,
as I said,
is a typical,
uh,
magnitude,
absolute magnitude.
And each color is a different supernova.
So they've made repeated observations of a large number of supernovae and then
the line is just connecting the dots,
connect,
connecting the observations.
And you can see from that top pla that it is not true that every supernova has
the same brightness,
uh,
at peak or at any other time.
Uh,
and so the green supernova on the bottom there gets up to about minus 18.8,
whereas the orange one on the top gets up to about minus 20.
That's almost a factor of three in,
in different of peak brightness.
Uh,
but then you can make this correction.
They measure the color of the thing,
which is not apparent on this particular plot.
They measured the rate of decay and that is apparent.
You can tell the green ones,
the ones at the bottom tend to fall off faster than the ones at the top.
Uh,
and they came up with a correction formula that allows,
uh,
the absolute magnitudes of these things to be corrected.
And that's what they plot here.
These are the same exact data points as they have on the,
on the top line except corrected for these,
uh,
for the differences in observed color and observe decay rate.
And you can see now you've got a very beautiful combined light curve where
everything does exactly the same thing as all the others.
And in particular,
the maximum brightness of these things is always the same at around minus 19 and
a half.
So you have to make this correction in order to be able to use these things
effectively,
uh,
as standard candles.
Uh,
and so when that was done and we had calibrated this and they thought,
well,
now we know every time we see one of these things,
we'll just follow it up,
follow it down,
make this correction.
And then we have a,
we know what the absolute magnitude is.
We measured the apparent magnitude.
We determine the distance.
Uh,
we get a spectrum along the way so that we can get a red shift and then we can
make these plots,
uh,
for distant objects.
These guys aren't particularly distant because you want to be able to get really
accurate measurements of them.
And so it,
this set,
we're the ones,
uh,
that were observed so close to us at,
at such low red shifts that you can't tell the different cosmological models
apart.
So then people got very fired up that said,
Aha,
we're going to figure out everything that is happening in the universe by
looking at these supernovae and they started up big observational projects to
find many high red shifts.
Supernovae so these things are going to be quite faint.
Uh,
they're going to be,
uh,
they have distance modulates as of close to 45.
Uh,
and so they'll have an,
uh,
an absolute,
apparent magnitudes as low as 25,
which is really very hard to see.
Um,
so here's what they do.
First of all,
let me just,
whoops,
let me just show you this picture.
This is just fun.
Uh,
let's see here.
If I do this,
that will be good,
except I think I want this.
There we go.
All right.
This is a photograph from the Hubble Space Telescope of empty space.
Uh,
they picked a part of the sky in which there was nothing,
uh,
actually that's not true.
There was one star,
one faint star that they knew about a and nothing else.
And they took this space telescope and they looked at it for about three weeks
in a row.
Uh,
and this is the picture they got.
Every,
you can see two or three stars in this picture.
This is one.
And there are a couple of others scattered around.
Uh,
you can tell they're stars because they have this sort of spike pattern from the
optics of the telescope.
Everything else that you see in this picture is a galaxy.
There's a whole galaxy.
Each one of them would,
billions of stars there are there I think a 13,000 of them.
8,000.
How many in the ultra deep field?
I don't remember.
Uh Huh.
A couple of them are lengths,
but most of them not a,
so most of them are just straight up images of it,
straight up images of galaxies.
You can see cc in the bigger ones,
some nice spirals,
uh,
and all the usual kinds of galaxies,
shapes.
This is a really small piece of the sky.
This is a piece of the sky,
about 1% of the area of the,
of the full moon.
So,
uh,
if you looked at the f,
the whole area covered by the full moon picture of the full moon or up in the
sky and you did this kind of picture,
you would discover literally millions of different galaxies.
So this means that you can discover supernovae.
And so there are thousands of supernovae.
It's thousands of galaxies here.
If a,
and if a supernovae occur once per every hundred years per galaxy,
there ought to be about 10 or 20 supernovae going off in this tiny piece of
space right now,
uh,
or any other such tiny piece of space.
And so if you're looking for high redshift,
Supernova,
you don't care where you point there everywhere.
And so you just put pick out some nice blank piece of space,
take really deep pictures of them and wait for the did start showing up.
Uh,
and this is what people people have done.
so here's here,
here's a,
uh,
a little bit of data from the Supernova cosmology project,
which is one of the groups that was attempting to do this in the late 1990s.
So in the background here is just a huge field of stars that they happened to be
looking at.
And then they've taken this tiny piece of the sky and blown it up.
So here's their first image of it.
By the way,
this and this and this,
these are all galaxies,
but they're taken from the ground instead of with the space telescope.
And so they looked like blobby things.
You can't see any of the structure.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
three weeks later they take another picture and it turns out there's a little
extra light on the side of one of the galaxies.
Now imagine taking something maybe a hundred times bigger than this whole
background picture and looking for that distance.
Uh,
you would make your graduate students completely cross side doing this.
and so they do it digitally.
They do it differently.
What you do is you take this picture,
each one of these pixels,
you know,
uh,
tells you exactly how many photons hit it.
So it's all digitized.
And each one of these is a number and you're just take this number and subtract
this number and you take the number from each pixel,
subtract the number that you got in the previous,
uh,
thing and get a subtracted image of how much light there is minus the light.
There was the last time you looked at it.
Here's the subtracted picture.
Now this even a blind old professor can see,
has something interesting going on.
There's a new object that has appeared between the first picture in the second
picture.
Now up at the top in the upper right hand corner there,
that's a Hubble space telescope picture taken of the same field while the
Supernova was in outbursts.
And you can see,
uh,
this galaxy here,
that's the galaxy,
you know,
below the Arrow there.
And then,
uh,
those two arrows,
are placed in exactly the same position,
relative position in the,
in these two pictures.
And so in that,
in the Hubble Space Telescope picture,
you can see that the additional light comes from a particular point in the
outskirts of a galaxy,
but it wasn't discovered with the Hubble space telescope because the HST doesn't
cover enough of the sky at once.
So you try and discover these things from the ground,
uh,
because you can cover so much more of the sky.
So this is a discovery image.
And then if you want more,
uh,
more precise imaging,
then you have to tell Hubble or I go and look at this particular place anyway.
Uh,
what they do is they keep at it,
they keep making you keep at it every three days.
They make one of these pictures,
they make these different pictures and they get these nice light curves and out
of those light curves,
they can then do the correction factor.
Uh,
and uh,
then,
uh,
once you've done that,
you also take a spectrum along the way for two purposes.
First of all,
to get the red shift.
Second of all,
to make sure that it's a type one a supernova rather than any of the other five
are six subtypes.
Um,
and then you put them on this plot,
uh,
and uh,
you plot their,
uh,
apparent magnitude corrected by these various factors against the red shift.
And that's how you come up with these kinds of data.
So that's where,
uh,
this information comes from.
MMM.
And there is,
as you see,
a kind of theoretical reason,
both a theoretical reason ant an observational reason to trust these results.
Uh,
so there is a theoretical basis
for thinking these things are standard candles,
namely that it's the same amount of fuel each time.
One of these things goes off.
And there's also an empirical basis,
which is that,
uh,
after some corrections,
the nearby ones line up beautiful.
The nearby ones for which you know,
the answer and advanced by other means,
uh,
the nearby ones line up well and whereby,
well,
I mean less than 5% difference between them.
Uh,
and uh,
there still is about,
uh,
a few percent difference.
Uh,
but if we observe enough of them,
we can average over that and we think we're going to be okay.
So if you want to come up with some kind of explanation for this that does not
involve dark energy,
uh,
you've got to get around both of these points,
namely,
uh,
the fact that we expect them to look like each other and the fact that they do
look like each other.
Now it's possible to do that.
And in fact,
one of the problems on the problem set addresses just this issue.
If you can invent some way,
the,
all of the supernovae at a red shift of 0.8,
high red shifts like that,
uh,
are all systematic.
We fainter then otherwise identical looking supernovae in the nearby universe,
then you can get around this problem.
But they have to be identical looking in the sense that they have the same color
and decay rate but are fainter.
We don't see that in the local,
in the local universe.
We don't see a category of things which have the same color and decay rate,
but one is fainter than the other.
But,
uh,
who knows?
Uh,
the universe was,
you know,
half its size back then.
All sorts of things were different.
Maybe there's some way that supernovae then we're systematically different from
how they are now,
except that they don't show it in these particular ways.
They only show it in the overall brightness.
That's tough.
Theoretically it's tough empirically.
Uh,
you know,
you would expect that.
If that were true,
then there will be intermediate cases that we could see and we don't see them.
Uh,
but you know,
shortly after this and the result was announced,
I used to,
when I was at conferences and stuff,
I would try and take the supernovae people off in a corner and give them beer.
And stuff until they would,
you know,
tell.
And then after you give them four beers,
you asked the question,
what could be going wrong?
Is it,
do you really believe in dark energy?
And then they start mumbling stuff about all the different weirdnesses that
supernovae have.
And of course,
these are people who have devoted their life to studying the weirdness of
supernovae.
And so they have many things that they,
uh,
we'll tell you a under cover of darkness,
which,
which of course then everybody went out to try and check.
And none of these things have turned out to be able to provide a satisfactory
explanation for the data except the idea that there's something very significant
cosmologically going up.
Okay.
Uh,
so from that point of view,
uh,
it's kind of hard to avoid believing this,
which disturbed a lot of people.
And in fact,
uh,
one of the reasons people,
belief this as quickly as they did was that in the Leighton in 1998 when this
was first announced,
uh,
it was not announced by one group.
It was announced by two different groups.
There were two groups trying to do the same thing,
uh,
doing the same thing.
And,
uh,
they said they were sort of spying on each other cause this was an important
result.
And they both found out at a certain point that the other guys had been spending
a year,
uh,
driving themselves crazy because they didn't believe their results.
They're saying,
look at this.
These things are getting these,
these things are going totally in the wrong direction.
We must be wrong somehow.
And it turned out that both of these groups had been spending the past year
trying to figure out why they are,
why their results were so screwed up.
But then they spied on each other and they found out that the other guys were
having the exact same problem having done,
taking their data and dealt with it and in quite a different way.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so then,
miraculously enough,
they kind of submitted their papers within 24 hours of each other,
uh,
until they both got credit.
Uh,
and so the two groups doing the same thing,
thanks things,
but doing them differently,
different approaches in some ways.
Uh,
got the same result,
particular one group where a bunch of particle physicists led by Saul Perlmutter
who had gotten depressed by the fact that the super collider was canceled in the
early 1990s and,
uh,
decided,
that somebody described this as adult onset cosmology,
uh,
where you used to be interested in particle physics but then they didn't build
your machine,
so now you're interested in astrophysics.
Uh,
and,
uh,
those guys,
those guys took a very particle physics approach to it.
They had a big team with,
with a team leader in a whole hierarchy.
The other guys were a bunch of Supernova.
Uh,
so,
and they were very expert in the cosmology side of things and in the dark energy
explanations and stuff like that.
The supernova experts,
the sort of guys who knew all the weirdness is about supernovae formed another
group,
but it was totally differently organized.
It was kind of a loose confederation of small research groups here and there.
They had done this interesting work,
uh,
with the correction factors on supernovae,
some years before.
And,
uh,
they approached it as,
you know,
uh,
my group,
we'll do this little piece,
we'll do this other little piece,
we'll get together over lunch and we'll figure out what's going on kind of
thing.
And they both got the same kinds of answers.
They both basically got the same answers.
Uh,
and so the,
this is one of the fables.
So fable,
uh,
discovery of dark energy.
Okay.
Eh,
and I would say that the moral here is that replicating
important results is important.
Results,
uh,
is one of the things that leads people to actually believe what you're saying
leads to a greater acceptance.
And it was protected.
Gillooly nice in this particular case because,
uh,
neither of them were replicating the others.
They both made the discovery independently at the same time using a very
different kind of organizational structure and a very different approach to
their data.
So this was a kind of compelling,
okay,
so
here we are,
Delta m minus M versus redshift.
Here's Omeka matter equals zero.
Omega Lambda Equals Zero.
Uh,
except that in fact the data,
you know,
they kind of look like this.
So this is Omega matter equals a quarter.
And Omega Lambda equals the reports.
And as you will recall,
the explanation for this or the first explanation that was offered was the fact
that Einstein had this figured out 80 years before except he decided he was
wrong.
And so the first explanation of this,
it was Einstein's cosmological constant.
That's this symbol lambda that I keep writing down.
And uh,
so what do people believe?
This result,
you have to start worrying about what the heck this actually is in real life.
Uh,
and it has some very peculiar properties in particular.
There is the issue of what is constant about Einstein's cosmological constant.
So let me first tell you what it is and then I'll tell you why it's so bizarre.
Uh,
it is the energy density.
Remember that's the crucial quantity,
uh,
of lambda is constant,
as the universe
expands.
So if you take one cubic meter of space and you say,
how much dark energy is there in this cubic meter of space where you take an
average cubic meter of space,
uh,
you can,
you figure that out by how fast the universe is being pushed apart.
Uh,
and then,
you know,
wait 10 billion years or something like that until the universe is very much
bigger.
Uh,
and then you take a cubic meter of space,
uh,
and you ask yourself how much energy,
dark energy is in this cubic meter?
And you get the same answer 10 billion years later and you've got the same
answer now,
and you would have gotten the same answer 10 billion years ago.
Very peculiar.
Right?
Do you see why,
think about matter?
You know,
the universal also has a bunch of matter in it.
All right?
Uh,
so I measured the average density of the universe and the way we've discussed,
and you get some answer.
So for matter,
you can get some density that your universe now and then supposing you imagined
in your mind,
you go back in time.
Uh,
and to the time when the scale factor of the universe,
when a was half its present,
uh,
size,
it's present of Mount.
Okay.
Uh,
but of course you have the same amount of matter in the universe.
Matter doesn't,
you know,
in general it doesn't get created or at least you have the same amount of matter
plus energy.
Uh,
so you go back to when you have the same amount of matter,
but it's in half the size,
by which I mean a one eighth,
the volume right?
A half squared,
half cube does innate.
Uh,
and so if I reduce the linear scale of the universe by a factor of two,
I have one eighth,
the volume,
uh,
but same amount of matter.
So row then,
okay.
Was,
uh,
which is equal to mass,
which doesn't change because there's the same amount of mass in the universe,
which doesn't
change
divided by volume,
which does change.
Uh,
so it has
to equal eight times the density.
Now we've talked about this before,
right?
The whole deal with the big bang is that if you go back into the past,
things were dancer than they were today.
Ah,
also harder,
which is uh,
uh,
a,
a byproduct.
If the density,
you take a big balloon full of stuff,
you make it smaller.
The same amount of stuff is in there.
It's gotta be denser inside the balloon.
After your squashed it down,
you take a balloon and you stretch it out.
If you don't let stuff come in or out,
then it has to be less dense af the stuff inside after you've stretched it out.
And then you get into all these nice little thermodynamics problems where you
have pressure is equal to density times temperature and things like that.
So I'll fill all of familiar,
uh,
gas physics comes into play.
And so you expect that the density of the universe is constantly getting smaller
because the universe is getting bigger and in fact there's extremely good
empirical evidence of that because you look back in time by looking at distant
things.
Sure enough,
it's denser back then,
but not the dark energy.
Dark energy density,
at least in Einstein's conception,
is constant.
So a cubic meter of the universe has the same amount of dark energy in it.
Now,
as a cubic meter of the universe did when the universe was only a cubic meter
across,
right where the whole of the observable universe was packed down into a cubic
meter,
that cubic meter had only as much dark,
yet dark energy in it as,
uh,
you know,
at this part of the universe does now very odd behavior.
Uh,
but this is what,
uh,
Einstein's equations predict.
Now
the thing is,
we don't know is that Einstein really was right.
Uh,
we don't because we don't have a clue what the dark energy actually is.
So let me,
uh,
so lambda the cosmological constant suggests that a dark energy has constant
density,
but since we don't know what the heck this stuff is,
maybe that's wrong,
uh,
or maybe not
okay.
If it's not,
we don't call it lambda anymore.
Uh,
but if you allow for changes in the density,
you can get very interesting potential effect.
And let me,
we'll talk about this more next time,
but let me just describe one at the very strange things that could happen.
Suppose it is true and this is not ruled out by the data we have so far.
Suppose that dark energy density
increases
as the universe gets bigger.
And since we don't have any idea what this stuff is,
it might do that and we can't rule it out by observations just yet.
Uh,
and so the universe gets bigger and bigger.
The density of the matter is going down because you have the same amount of
matter,
uh,
in,
in a bigger space.
But supposing we invent some kind of dark energy where the density actually gets
bigger,
as the universe increases in size,
then
uh,
a cubic meter of volume
has increasing
dark energy as time goes along.
That of course,
pushes the universe out faster.
So the acceleration increases that makes the size increase.
Okay.
And you get a feedback
as the universe exponentially expands,
you're getting exponential expansion.
And as that exponential expansion,
sorry,
expansion.
Yeah.
Has that exponential expansion increases the amount of dark energy in any
particular cubic meter?
Get Speaker too.
And so what happens after a while,
the dark energy in any cubic galaxy has become so much that it blows the galaxy
apart.
Uh,
gap gravity can't hold the galaxy together.
And then the expansion continues.
And then,
uh,
after a while,
the amount of dark energy in one cubic star,
uh,
if I can use that term,
in one star becomes so great that it overcomes the gravity of the star,
blows the star apart.
And then the expansion continues even faster.
And after a while,
the amount of,
uh,
dark energy in a cubic meter that would be a human being,
remember,
he'd been human beings have exact,
are exactly a cubic meter and exactly 100 kilograms in mass,
uh,
the,
amount of dark energy and a human being overcomes the chemical bonds that hold
your body together and human beings get blown apart.
And eventually you have so much dark matter that whole Adams that Adam's get
blown to bits.
And even the subatomic particles that are,
uh,
are we,
they of them eventually get blown to bits and you'd get,
and so,
uh,
dark energy conquers all.
This is,
uh,
described as the big rip.
Uh,
and it is kind of an alternative,
a hypothesis of what might happen to the universe.
Uh,
that stems from an alternative hypothesis of what the dark energy is,
uh,
that there's no particular reason to believe,
but that hasn't been disproved.
And since there's no particular reason to believe anything else,
you can amuse your students by talking about it.
Uh,
so,
uh,
to summarize this here is it's all a question of the scale factor versus time.
Here's now,
here's one.
Here's an empty universe.
Uh,
we thought that what would happen is that it would look like this and then
either collapse or not.
Uh,
what actually happened is it turns out,
uh,
it turns out things look like this.
We only really observe it in the past.
So there's a whole bunch of supernovae proving that that's true.
And you can extrapolate a kind of gentle expansion that looks like this.
This is the standard model
with,
uh,
a cosmological constant.
But if you assume that things get even bigger,
uh,
that the,
dark energy increases per volume with time,
then you ask them tonic,
we go to infinity at some time in the future and you blow everything apart,
not ruled out.
Uh,
and so people are anxious to discover whether that or some other set of crazy
ideas might be true.
And we'll talk about how people are going about trying to nail this down next
time.
Thanks.